Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Ja, wir sprechen endlich wieder über die 2. Bundesliga hier im Kurzpass. Es wird Zeit in Ausgabe Nr. 144. Spreche ich jetzt mit Eva vom 2. Bundesliga Podcast. Eva, herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk.
Hallo, ich freue mich, dass ich hier sein darf.
Ich finde es auch schon, dass du endlich mit dabei bist. Ich habe es schon im Vorgespräch gesagt, du stehst schon ewig auf der potenziellen Gästeliste, denn du bist ja selber im Podcastbereich in der 2. Liga aktiv. Du musst jetzt für dieses Format Werbung machen. Eva, weil so viele 2. Liga-Podcasts, die auf die Liga blicken, gibt es ja nicht.
Nee, ich finde es auch echt überraschend, dass es doch relativ wenige dafür gibt. Also wenn man sich mal die ganze Breite an Fußball-Podcasts anguckt. Und dann natürlich auch noch auf Englisch, das ist ja schon ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal für uns und generell für die Liga. Ich bin auch immer wieder überrascht, wie viele Leute sich das tatsächlich anhören.
Wie viele sind das denn, kannst du sagen?
Ich glaube im Schnitt so um die 500 bis 1000, was ich schon ziemlich viel finde. Dafür, wenn man mal überlegt, welche Vereine in dieser Liga spielen. Also ich habe keine Ahnung von irgendwelchen zweiten französischen Ligen oder so. Aber das macht auf jeden Fall auch immer wieder Spaß. Schön, wie viele Leute sich dafür interessieren, auch daran teilhaben, uns Fragen einschicken und so. Und das macht wirklich Spaß. Ich kann jedem empfehlen, auch mal reinzuhören, weil wir auch sehr viele unterschiedliche Gäste haben.
Absolut. Also auf Twitter der at2bundesligapod, also 2 als Ziffer, das 2. Bundesliga-Podcast, so findet ihr den. Und dich kann man finden auf Twitter als atlottibohle, du bist Arminia-Fan und eben da zu hören und jetzt endlich auch mal im Rasenfunk. Und mit der Arminia müssen wir, können wir, dürfen wir ja auch dann in diesem Blick auf die 2. Liga starten, denn die Grüßen von der Tabellenspitze. Eva mit 38 Punkten, 3 Punkte Vorsprung. Wir müssen dazu sagen, wir nehmen am Montagabend auf, aber bevor der HSV sein Auswärtsspiel bei Bochum bestritten hat, also sprich, die Punkte können sich da noch ganz leicht verschieben, aber unter dem Strich bleibt ja die Arminia, spielt eine sehr, sehr gute Saison. Woran liegt denn das?
Ich glaube, es liegt primär erst mal in Uwe Neuhaus. Ich glaube, da braucht man auch alleine nur auf die Jahrestabelle 2019 zu gucken. Das ist schon unglaublich, was der geleistet hat. Dann natürlich Klos und Vogelsammer, die alleine, so weit ich weiß, 24 Tore erzielt haben zusammen.
Von 37.
Also keine schlechte Nummer. Ja, wenn man jetzt überlegt, dass Vogelsammer verletzt, ist das nicht so super, aber trotzdem erst mal schon ziemlich gut. Man hat momentan in der Saison nur zwei Niederlagen. Das sind die wenigsten Niederlagen in den ersten drei deutschen Ligen. Also alle anderen Tabellenführer und Co. haben auf jeden Fall mehr. Und generell unter Uwe Neuhaus nur sechs Niederlagen und da auf der anderen Seite stehen 20 Siege, 72 Punkte unter ihm. Das ist schon eine ziemlich gute Leistung. Und das merkt man der Mannschaft und der Stadt generell auch einfach an.
Genau, und über dieses Duo Klos und Vogelsammler, da haben wir auch im letzten Zweitliga-Kurzpass. Die Älteren unter den Hörern werden sich noch an ihn erinnern. Das ist schon ein paar Monate her. Über die haben wir schon damals gesprochen. Und alles, was damals gesagt wurde, hat sich dann noch mal fast multipliziert, möchte man sagen. Die haben einfach nicht aufgehört, sich gegenseitig Tore aufzulegen, Tore zu erzielen. Jetzt hat sich Vogelsammer den Fuß gebrochen, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Ja genau, Mittelfußknochen.
Das heißt, das ist eine schwerere Verletzung. Was glaubst du denn jetzt, was davon die Auswirkungen sein werden?
Ja, wir brauchen natürlich irgendwie einen neuen Sturmduo, Partner für Klos. Bieten sich ein paar Leute an, also einmal Sebiou Soukou, der im Sommer gekommen ist aus Rostock, der auch immer wieder spielt, seine Einsatzminuten hat, sich glaube ich noch ein bisschen durchsetzen muss. Dann Johann Simon Edmundson, den man aber auch schon etwas länger kennt jetzt bei Arminia, der generell auch Tore schießen kann und zum Beispiel in der Faröer Nationalmannschaft auch den traditionellen Mittelstürmer gibt quasi. Ja und dann die anderen beiden Alternativen sind halt Keanu Staude, der aber seit mindestens zwei Spielen schon gar nicht mehr zum Kader dazu gehört und einen Youngster, was ich als sehr unwahrscheinlich erachte, weil der gerade erst von einer U-Mannschaft, ich glaube der U19-Mannschaft von Köln gekommen ist, Sebastian Müller und der auch noch kein richtiges Spiel für uns gemacht hat. Also ich nehme mal stark an, am Sonntag jetzt gegen Regensburg wird es auf Suku hinauslaufen.
Und wie würdest du jetzt so die aktuelle Situation bei der Arminia einschätzen? Wenn ich mir jetzt mal die letzten sieben Spiele angucke, klar dazwischen lag eine Winterpause, also darf man jetzt nicht so, das darf man jetzt nicht überzeichnen, das Bild, aber aus den letzten sieben Spielen sehe ich vier Unentschieden, eine Niederlage bei St. Pauli und nur zwei Siege. Das heißt, der Vorsprung, er könnte noch viel höher sein, wenn man nicht so ein bisschen nachgelassen hätte. Ich will jetzt nicht vom Einbruch oder sowas zu sprechen, das wäre ja Quatsch. Aber ist das jetzt mehr als nur eine Ergebniskrise? Glaubst du, das könnte jetzt mal in eine andere Richtung gehen? Von hinten schieben ja auch die Vereine Stuttgart, HSV nach und andere, über die wir auch noch sprechen werden?
Ja, also die Gefahr besteht natürlich immer. Also wenn man gerade mal die Kaderstärke einfach nur vergleicht oder ähnliches, dann –also jeder kennt Arminia und irgendwie ist jedem auch bewusst, dass das jetzt bis Mai nicht so weiter gehen wird und dass noch wirklich schwere Spiele folgen. Auf der anderen Seite denke ich, dass nach dem 3-0 gegen St. Pauli, also viel schlechter können wir nicht mehr spielen in dieser Saison, also wirklich nicht. Und ich glaube, das war so ein Aufwachmoment. Also auch das Spiel gegen Aue, die ja selber nicht unbedingt schlechter stehen in der Tabelle, die aber sich trotzdem irgendwie ab der 40. Minute mit elf Mann in die eigene Hälfte verschanzt haben. Da sieht man auch so, wie die anderen Mannschaften jetzt auf Arminia reagieren. Das können auch wirklich gemeine Spiele werden, aber ich glaube, also selbst mit Vogelsamm als Ausfall, dass man nicht unter, also tiefer rutscht als unter die ersten vier oder fünf. Hoffe ich.
Ja, ja gut. Das ist ja eh klar. Das sei dir ja auch sehr gegönnt. Ich hatte ja die Arminia, da muss ich jetzt allerdings auch sagen, da greife ich auf ein Fußballkultures Wissen zurück, was schon erschreckend alt ist. Ich hatte Arminia als eine starke Heimmannschaft in Erinnerung. Jetzt gucke ich mir nach den aktuellen 20 gespielten Spielen mal Heim- und Auswärtstabelle an und sehe, dieses Jahr ist es nicht so. In der Heim-Tabelle liegt man auf Tabellenplatz 11, in der Auswärtstabelle auf dem ersten Platz und da auch mit unglaublichen 24 Punkten. Also auswärts ist Arminia bockstark. Was ist denn da für die Erklärung?
Ich glaube, das kann diese komplette Mannschaft selber nicht so ganz beantworten. Das klingt auch immer ein bisschen durch, wenn man sich die Spieltagsanalysen anhört. Ich habe ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass Arminia besser auf andere Mannschaften reagiert, wenn man Auswärts spielt. Also man kann sich irgendwie mehr darauf einstellen, naja zu Hause spielen sie so und so und es geht natürlich viel. Es wird ja viel aus der eigenen Hälfte aufgebaut und das geht halt nicht, wenn du zu Hause eine Mannschaft hast, die ab der ersten Minute anrennt und die dann immer dein komplettes Gegenpressing stört. Und ich glaube, das ist Auswärts für Arminia einfacher. Auf der anderen Seite muss man sich auch die Vereine aus der Hinrunde angucken, gegen die wir zu Hause gespielt haben. Da ist der HSV dabei, da ist Stuttgart dabei, da ist Heidenheim dabei. Das sind alles drei Mannschaften, die auch wirklich stark sind wieder diese Saison. Auswärts waren dann Spiele wie Hannover, Regensburg war dabei auswärts, aber irgendwie in Nürnberg, genau wie in Wiesbaden. Also man muss es halt auch in Relation sehen, glaube ich. Es kann halt jetzt zur Rückrunde komplett kippen. Wir haben ja zum Beispiel am Anfang direkt das Spiel gegen Bochum gewonnen, dafür unentschieden in Aue gespielt. Ich denke mal, das kann auch noch kippen. Also ich meine, der Start in die Rückrunde war ja die 3-0-Niederlage gegen St. Pauli. Also ich glaube wirklich, dass das Gegner abhängig ist und gar nicht mal so sehr auf Heim- und Auswärts gelegt werden kann.
Aber das sieht ja dann eigentlich, sind das ja eher gute Nachrichten dann für die Arminia. Also wenn ich mir jetzt mal die Heimgegner angucke in dieser Rückrunde, dann sehe ich da Hannover 690, ich sehe Wien-Wiesbaden, ich sehe Osnabrück, ich sehe Dynamo Dresden. Das sind jetzt alle Vereine, die zumindest aktuell in großen Problemen stecken und die werden sich nicht alle von da unten spielerisch raus befreien. Das sieht ja danach aus, als könnte man diese Chance vielleicht irgendwie, um den Aufstieg an Wort mitzureden und das vielleicht umzusetzen in der Saison wirklich mal umsetzen.
Ja, das ist auch irgendwie so ein bisschen meine Hoffnung, dass man halt wirklich auf diesen tukenden, sag ich mal, der Hinrunde beruht und dass einfach immer diesen ganzen Kommentaren von wegen ja, hier und jetzt müssen sie ja einbrechen, einfach auch nicht so viel Glauben schenkt. Und ich glaube, da hat man aber mit Uwe Neuhaus auch jemanden, der die Liga einfach unfassbar gut kennt, der weiß, wie es ist, unter Druck zu stehen. Und das ist, glaube ich, was jetzt für den Rest der Saison auch echt wichtig ist. Es ist wichtig, dass einfach nicht so viele Veränderungen jetzt auch in der Winterpause gemacht wurden. Auch wenn man vielleicht dann noch hätte, einen Stürmer dazu verpflichten können. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen ärgerlich. Weil man hat ja theoretisch noch zwei Stürmer auf der Bank sitzen, während sie nicht dauerverletzt werden, mit Nils Quaschner und Sven Schiplock. Das ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen ärgerlich. Aber ja, das ist halt der Vorteil der Arminia vielleicht gegenüber Stuttgart und den HSV auch. Hier ist keiner richtig, richtig sauer, wenn man am Ende der Saison nicht aufsteigt, weil man eben nicht den Druck hat. Also ganz ehrlich, wenn ich mir Vereine wie Paderborn jetzt angucke, die durch die zweite Liga marschiert sind und jetzt einfach wieder kurz davor stehen abzusteigen, ist man in Bielefeld auch so ein bisschen drauf nach dem Motto, ja, es muss nix hier, wirklich.
Ja, das ist ein großer Vorteil. Wir haben jetzt über die Offensive gesprochen und ja auch so ein bisschen die Spielweise schon zumindest angedeutet von der Arminia. Der Aspekt, der aber vielleicht da so ein bisschen untergeht, zumindest wenn ich mir die Zahlen anschaue, ist die gute Defensive. Also man hat jetzt auch mit 21 Gegentreffern aktuell die zweitbeste Abwehr der Liga und man lässt auch die zweitwenigsten Schüsse aufs eigene Tor zu. Also welche Rolle spielt denn da die Defensive und wer sind da dann vor allem die entscheidenden Namen? Denn Klos und Vogelsammer, das hat jetzt glaube ich so jeder Fußballfan sich schon abgespeichert, dass die zu Bielefeld gehören und zum Erfolg von Bielefeld.
Ja also ich glaube die Hauptcharaktere da sind sowohl einfach schon der Torwart, weil mit Stefan Ortega haben wir jemanden, der sowohl einfach schon Spiel gut aufbauen kann, als auch wirklich stark ist. Und dann sind es die Innenverteidiger, was glaube ich keiner vor der Saison gedacht hatte, mit Amos Pieper und Joachim Nilsson, die eher gezwungen wurden, kurz nach Beginn der Hinrunde zusammenzuspielen, weil Bären sich im Spiel gegen Regensburg einen Bänderes oder Kreuzbandriss zugezogen hat. Und Pieper ja noch sehr jung ist, also der ist glaube ich gerade mal 21 und wenn man dem mal beim Fußballspielen zuguckt, das sieht man dem wirklich nicht an. Und die sind beide relativ ruhig, also die machen beide immer wieder Fehler, das ist leider so, aber trotzdem spielen die das echt gut runter und ich glaube der Vorteil, den Neuhaus da auch hat, der ändert nicht so gerne seine Startelf-Aufstellung und dann die Formationen können wechseln, also alles von 4-3-3, 4-2-3-1, schieß mich tot, was da alles noch gibt, aber es ist halt immer die Viererkette, die hinten drin bleibt und die bleibt so meistens auch bestehen. Es gibt zwar mal Änderungen, aber ich glaube, das ist das größte Geheimnis dahinter, dass die einfach da so konstant bleibt und dass man, wenn man Ballverlust in der eigenen oder gegnerischen Hälfte hat, müssen sich nicht die Defensivleute da als erstes drum kümmern, sondern es gehen die Offensivleute dran, sodass die Defensive genug Zeit hat, sich wieder einzufinden in der Formation und dann das relativ ruhig wieder zu Ende gespielt werden kann, in den meisten Fällen.
Das sieht doch alles ganz positiv aus. Du hast angesprochen, dass sehr wenig gewechselt wird. Es gibt zwei Spieler, die bisher alle Minuten in dieser Saison für Bielefeld gemacht haben. Das sind eben Stefan Ortega und Florian Hartherz, der Linksverteidiger. Möchtest du zudem noch ein Wort verlieren oder sollen wir weitermachen?
Ja, also, wenn man sich im Bielefelder Umfeld mal umhört, ist Florian Hartherz jetzt nicht der größte Liebling.
Ist das nur in deinem Umfeld so oder kann man das auch generalisieren?
Das kann man glaube ich tatsächlich generalisieren. Also, was man mal sagen muss, ist, ja, ich glaube Bielefelder sind ja generell traditionell etwas pessimistisch oder wie wir sagen realistisch. Und sehen gerne immer als erstes das Schlechte. Also, was man sagen muss, der hat sich unfassbar gesteigert in den Jahren, die er da ist. Der hat eine richtig gute Antrittsgeschwindigkeit. Nur nutzt er sie leider nur zum nach vorne Laufen und nicht zum, also nach hinten. Es ist manchmal wirklich erschreckend, wie lange der braucht, um zurückzulaufen. Der hat nicht wirklich das beste Stellungsspiel. Manchmal gibt es Spiele, in denen man denkt, es ist schön, dass du da vorne die Flanke gebracht hast, aber du bist halt auch immer noch Abwehrmann. Wäre schön, wenn du da auch wieder bist. Ich glaube, das ist manchmal noch das Problem. Und man hat theoretisch eine Alternative, das Anason Lukoki. Der hat zum Beispiel im Pokalspiel gegen Schalke echt kein schlechtes Spiel dafür gemacht. Also, lässt das Halbzeitergebnis mit 3-0 nicht vermuten. Aber der ist halt so ein bisschen giftiger. Das Ding ist halt, dass Hardheads wirklich, also, dem merkt man das nach 90 Minuten auch nicht an, dass der 90 Minuten gelaufen ist. Und ich glaube, der spult auch die meisten Kilometer in der ganzen Liga ab zum Teil. Nur manchmal sieht man es leider nicht. Also, irgendwas muss er ja auch richtig machen, weil, wie du ja schon richtig gesagt hast, er hat bis jetzt auch keine Minute verpasst. Ich würde mir halt jetzt gerade wünschen, wenn es in die zweite Hälfte der Saison geht, dass man da auf der Stelle vielleicht echt noch mal ein bisschen rotiert. Sonst hat er jetzt mal ein bisschen nach vorne rückt, das kann er bestimmt auch. Aber, ja, manchmal, weil wir rechts mit Brunner auch noch jemanden haben, der auch noch nicht wieder komplett auf seinem Fitnesslevel ist, ist es halt ein bisschen schwierig, wenn man die beiden Außenverteidiger, zwei Personen hat, die gerne mal wackeln und dann halt alles auf den Innenverteidigern lastet.
Ja, aber jetzt kommen wir fast negativer aus diesem Segment raus, als ich das eigentlich wollte. Ich bin da auf unser Vorgespräch eingegangen. Machen wir mal einen Strich drunter, jetzt unter der bisherigen Bestandsaufnahme zu Bielefeld. Jetzt mit der Verletzung von Vogelsammer und dem Rückrundenprogramm verändern sich ja sowieso ein paar Dinge. Und man wird sehen, welche Dynamik diese Saison noch nimmt für die Arminia. Hinter der Arminia, zumindest stand unserer Aufnahme, liegt der VfB aus Stuttgart. Auch jetzt keine komplett unbekannte Mannschaft mit drei Punkten Rückstart aktuell. Die haben im Vergleich zur Arminia schon fünfmal verloren. Also ihr erinnert euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, zwei Niederlagen für Bielefeld, fünf Niederlagenstunden für den VfB. Wie siehst du denn euren Konkurrenten um den Aufstieg?
Ja, es ist irgendwie nicht so ganz einfach, die zu definieren. Also ich glaube unter Tim Walther –und ich glaube, da braucht man auch kein großes Fußballgenie zu sein, um das zu erkennen –war diese Mannschaft hoffnungslos überfordert. Also wenn man sich da zum Teil Spiele angeguckt hat gegen Wien, Wiesbaden, wo die ja irgendwie glorreich verloren haben, das ist unter Pellegrino Matarasa, also den Trainer, den sie jetzt in der Winterpause geholt haben, eindeutig besser. Das hat man zumindest im Heidenheim-Spiel gesehen. Darauf folgte dann dieses St. Pauli-Spiel, das man mal gerade so mit 1-1 noch über die Runden gebracht hat. Stuttgart ist für mich so ein bisschen die Überraschungskiste in dieser Saison. Also die haben ja endlich einen unfassbar starken Kader. Also ich meine, wer jemand wie Mario Gomez irgendwie noch auf der Gehaltsliste hat, mal in der 2. Liga, weiß man ja irgendwie schon, dass da theoretisch nicht so viel falsch laufen kann. Aber die haben jetzt natürlich auch das Pech, dass sie im Winter Santi Askazciva verloren haben, nach Berlin und dass jetzt deren Kapitän Marc-Oliver Kempf ausfällt, weil er einen Kieferbruch hat und die jetzt mehr oder weniger keine vernünftige Innenverteidigung mehr haben. Und es wird sehr, sehr viel rotiert in dieser Mannschaft. Also ich kann mich an kaum drei aufeinander vollen Spiele erinnern, wo irgendwie mal die gleiche Elf auf dem Platz stand. Also im Prinzip genau das Gegenteil zu Bielefeld. Und man hat immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl, sobald die gegen Mannschaften antreten, die ein sehr rigoroses Zweikampfverhalten haben, treten da sehr viele Probleme auf. Also dass die mit dieser, eigentlich dass Stuttgart mit dieser Favoritenrolle nicht so ganz gut umgehen kann. Und ich glaube, das wird in den nächsten Wochen auch nicht einfacher, weil man hat die Doppelbelastung mit dem Pokal gegen Leverkusen. Und dann folgen noch Spiele gegen Aue, Bochum und Regensburg. Also erst mal klare Siege, aber auf der anderen Seite sind das alle auch Vereine, die inzwischen noch relativ wenig zu verlieren haben gegen jemanden wie Stuttgart. Und das wären, glaube ich, keine leichten sieben Tage für die.
Vor allem Aue auch sehr heimstark. Das hat ja auch gerade die Arminia jetzt zu schmecken bekommen am letzten Spieltag. Das eben nach dem DFB-Pokalspiel und Bochum halt mit dem Mute der Verzweiflung, über die werden wir, glaube ich, später noch kurz sprechen. Also du verstehst den VfB auch nicht. Ich glaube, das tröstet viele VfB-Fans, die das jetzt hören.
Ja, ich war ja auch eingeladen zu einem VfB-Podcast und bin da auch noch mit zwei davon in Kontakt und das klingt da auch immer ein bisschen durch, dass sie auch nicht so richtig verstehen, was da gerade läuft. Der Druck ist da halt viel größer. Also wenn man da einfach nochmal Zahlen reinwirft, alleine das Geld, was für Neuzugänge ausgegeben wurde, das sind 21 Millionen. Im Verhältnis dazu hat Arminia 1,04 Millionen für Neuzugänge ausgegeben und selbst der HSV 012. Und dafür kommt er erstaunlich wenig, finde ich zum Teil. Also gerade wieder das St. Pauli-Spiel oder auch über ein paar Strecken im Heidenheim-Spiel, das war echt keine gute Leistung und ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, Stuttgart will zu viel Technik und manchmal wäre es einfacher, wenn sie einfach Fußball spielen, der für die 2. Liga komplett reicht.
Ja, wobei beim VfB merkt man schon, dass was häufig so etablierte Erstligisten, die runtergehen in die 2. Liga, haben, gegen die tritt auch fast jede Mannschaft anders auf als gegen Zweitligisten Nummer XY. Also der VfB hat zum Beispiel mit weitem Abstand den meisten Ballbesitz in dieser Liga. 62 Prozent Ballbesitz pro Spiel. Dahinter kommt der HSV mit 56 Prozent. Also ein deutlicher Unterschied und das hat halt nicht nur damit zu tun, dass der VfB aus dem Ballbesitzspiel heraus seine Tore erzielen möchte und da kommen natürlich auch noch so Team-Walter-Zeiten mit rein, sondern halt auch, weil eigentlich ist es für jeden Gegner, egal ob zu Hause oder auswärts, völlig okay ist, sich gegen den VfB einfach erstmal hinten reinzustellen und zu sagen, so, jetzt macht erst mal, ihr habt den Druck, ihr habt auch die Probleme und wir gucken dann mal, so was für uns herunterfällt und ich glaube, das merkt man beim VfB, glaube ich, gerade am deutlichsten in der ganzen Liga, dass die Haltung, mit der dir alle anderen Vereine begegnen, da eine Rolle spielt.
Ja, also auch zu dem Ballbesitz, was du meintest, die haben auch die meisten, wenn ich das richtig sehe, die meisten kurzen Pässe pro Spiel quasi mit 540 im Schnitt. Das ist, vergleichsweise danach kommt der HSV erst mit 458, also ähnliche Verhältnisse auch wie beim Ballbesitz. Also da geht schon sehr, sehr viel über Ballbesitz, aber man hat halt das Gefühl, dass die Passgenauigkeit da zwischendurch mal ein bisschen verloren geht, obwohl die immer noch sehr, sehr hoch ist. Aber es ist halt vergleichsweise, passt da halt vieles nicht. Also die müssen halt das Spiel oft machen, weil sie eben die Favoriten sind und können damit manchmal aber nicht so ideal umgehen.
Und wie würdest du jetzt da im Vergleich den HSV einordnen? Der liegt aktuell, wie gesagt, wir wissen noch nicht, wie das Spiel in Bochum ausgegangen sein wird, zu einem Zeitpunkt, zu dem ihr das hier hört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber da liegen sie eben auf Tabellenplatz 3 mit 34 Punkten. Das heißt, je nachdem, wie das jetzt gelaufen ist, hat man vier Punkte Rückstand auf die Arminias, könnte aber auch nur ein Pünktchen sein. Unterscheidet sich der HSV vom VfB?
Ja, ich glaube, die haben erst mal weniger Druck als Stuttgart. Also sie sind dadurch, dass der HSV jetzt in seiner zweiten Bundesliga, also in seiner zweiten Zweitliga-Saison spielt. Die haben viel gelernt in der Sommerpause, hatte ich so das Gefühl. Also alleine schon die Neuzugänge, die man geholt hat. Jetzt auch in der Winterpause mit Louis Schaub. Also wenn man den gegen Nürnberg gesehen hat, hat er ein super Spiel hingelegt, hat sich schon super in die Mannschaft integriert. Und da hat man das Gefühl, dass mit Dieter Hecking jemand da Trainer ist, der die Sachen oder das komplette Verhältnis in der Liga etwas entspannter sieht. Also der ist natürlich super erfahren, weiß irgendwie so ein bisschen, wie der Hase läuft, anders als Walter oder auch Matarazzo. Der weiß einfach, wie er eine Mannschaft zu motivieren hat. Und das sieht man auch. Also wenn ich den Fußball vom HSV diese Saison mit der letzten Saison vergleiche, das ist wieder vernünftiger Fußball. Also das ist irgendwie dann auch ein Fußball, wo ich zum Teil das Gefühl habe, dass die HSV-Fans denken, so ja, können wir gerne so weiter spielen, wenn wir dann so auch mal in der Bundesliga spielen könnten.
Aber wie unterscheidet das sich dann? Also ich sehe von den nackten Zahlen, dass der HSV gerade den besten Angriff und die beste Abwehr der Liga stellt. Also es scheint zu laufen bei Hamburg. Aber was ist das, wo du sagen würdest, das ist jetzt vernünftig im Vergleich zur letzten Saison?
Ja, ich glaube, es sind tatsächlich die Stürmer, die man vorne drin hat, die einen Unterschied machen einmal. Also mit Kittel, aber auch Leute wie Fein oder so, die da diese Mischung macht im Prinzip, die sich da super ergänzen. Die haben jemanden, zum Beispiel mit Jatta oder so, also die Angriffe, die da über die Flanken oder die Flügel kommen im Prinzip, die sind immer superschnell und aber eben auch sehr genau gesetzt. Also ich weiß, dass das Heimspiel gegen den HSV da stand, in der ersten Halbzeit, unter Dauerbeschuss quasi. Und die haben einfach eine unfassbare Klasse in der Mannschaft. Aber sie spielen es etwas ruhiger als Stuttgart. Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, die brauchen, also die sind einfach stärker im Abschluss als Stuttgart. Ich habe da jetzt keine Zahlen, die das belegen. Aber die Chancenverwertung beim HSV scheint einfach besser zu sein.
Und gleichzeitig steht die Abwehr besser. Also in der ersten Zweitligasaison des HSV, kann ich mich noch an einige Spiele erinnern, die so merkwürdige Dynamiken hatten. Also wo du nach vergebenen Chancen oder nach einem guten Angriff des Gegners richtig sehen konntest, okay, jetzt kippt auf einmal das ganze Spiel und jetzt geht es wieder dahin. Und die HSV-Fans haben da auch sehr früh dann schon so einen Fatalismus entwickelt. Oh je, jetzt verlieren wir das wieder, obwohl sie noch 1 zu 0 geführt haben. Und sie haben aber dann tatsächlich häufig Recht behalten. Und an solche Spiele kann ich mich jetzt in dieser Saison, ich habe aber logischerweise jetzt auch nicht alles gesehen vom HSV, aber viel, viel weniger erinnern. Ich habe das Gefühl, egal, selbst wenn die mal 0-1 in Rückstand geraten, was jetzt auch gar nicht so häufig vorgekommen ist, aber selbst dann haben die einfach so eine grundstabile Grundordnung und vielleicht hat es auch mit mentalen Dingen zu tun, dass sie einfach weiter ihren Fußball spielen und damit halt dann auch sehr erfolgreich sind, weil die Qualität ist ja da.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich glaube, die haben ja ein Torverhältnis von plus 20. Ich meine 40 geschossene Tore nur 20 kassiert. Das ist natürlich in 20 Spieltagen, da braucht man jetzt sich nicht großartig auszusetzen, das ist nur ein Gegentor pro Spiel. Und das ist sowieso Liga-Bestwert, aber das ist generell im Prinzip nicht das, was man früher mit dem HSV verbunden hat. Also irgendwie die ganzen Bundesliga-Jahre auch, wie du schon sagst, das letzte Jahr, das ist glaube ich die Basis, die für den HSV auch einfach für den Ausstieg wichtig ist und das, was sie im Prinzip auch zum Ausstieg bringen wird. Weil man sieht, dass eine gute Offensive in dieser Liga nichts heißt, wenn man sich zum Beispiel immer Bochum anguckt, die eine super Offensive haben, aber eine katastrophale Defensive. Und das ist genau das HSV, da wird den richtigen Mix diese Saison erwischt, haben sich super verstärkt, wissen, wen sie wo haben müssen und jeder scheint seinen Platz in der Mannschaft zu kennen. Und ich glaube, das ist unfassbar wichtig und das ist was, was der HSV und dem Stuttgart voraus ist.
Dann schauen wir mal, wie es beim HSV weiterläuft. Es sieht aktuell ganz gut aus, aber HSV-Fans sehen das häufig dann noch ein bisschen anders. Man ist halt auch ein gebranntes Kind. Hinter dem HSV, dem VfB und Arminia tauchen gleich mehrere Vereine auf, mit denen man jetzt nicht unbedingt gerechnet hätte zu diesem Zeitpunkt in der Saison. Wir sprechen über Kreuter Fürth, den FC Heidenhamn und Erzgebirge Aue. Die liegen mit jeweils 31 bzw. 30 Punkten Aue knapp hinter diesem Spitzen-Trio in der 2. Liga. Was sind da so die bemerkenswerten Dinge? Wie sind die da hingekommen? Kannst du mir das erklären? Erkläre dich, Eva.
Ja, ich muss sagen, ich hab's im Vorgespräch schon gesagt. Ich war doch etwas erschrocken, dass Fürth jetzt auf Platz 4 steht.
Das hören die so gerne.
Obwohl man sagen muss, es führt schon extrem gut in die Saison gestartet ist. Also da waren die schon mal in den oberen Gefilden, sag ich mal. Und sie sind jetzt auch sehr gut in die Rückrunde gestartet, also mit sechs Punkten aus drei Spielen. Und generell zum Beispiel mit jemandem wie Brani Miohogotha, der neun Tore in 18 Spielen geschossen hat, sind die relativ solide dabei. Aber sie haben eben auch sieben Niederlagen. Und das sind die meisten Niederlagen unter den Top. Sechs, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Und das ist natürlich was, was einen dann doch ein bisschen verwundert, dass sie dennoch so weit oben stehen. Aber sie haben eben halt auch neun Siege. Und ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel, wie ich dazu sagen soll. Ich hab's auch im Vorgespräch schon gesagt, das hat mich wirklich ein bisschen verwundert. Weil Führt für mich immer nicht so rüberkommt wie die spielstärkste Mannschaft. Ich glaube, die sind relativ giftig, was Konter betrifft. Die sind sehr effizient. Also die nutzen sehr effizient ihre Chancen. Die passen sehr gut auf, nutzen jeden Fehler, den der Gegner macht. Da kann man in Bielefeld auch ein Lied von singen. Aber ich muss wirklich sagen, es überrascht mich doch. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie sich an diesem Platz sehr lange halten werden können.
Ja, wer weiß, vielleicht strafen sie uns dann natürlich Lügen. Aber die vier Unentschieden im Vergleich zu den Mannschaften, die sonst so in diesem Umfeld liegen, die deuten schon darauf hin, dass es entweder in die eine oder in die andere Richtung kippt bei Kräuter Fürth. Und was ich so gesehen habe, weiß aber auch nicht so viel. Ehrlich gesagt, es ist halt wirklich sehr viel vertikales Spiel, Passquote dann gar nicht so hoch, logischerweise. Und dann stehst du eben manchmal auch relativ häufig in Situationen, in denen du alleine vom Torhüter stehst, oder nur noch einen Querpass kommen muss. Und der wird dann manchmal abgerätscht, manchmal nicht. Aber das kreiert man eben auch nicht immer. Vor allem, wenn die Gegner vielleicht dann irgendwann auch drauf reagieren, wie Fürth dasteht. Was ist denn zu Heidenheim und Aue zu sagen? Bei Heidenheim hat man halt immer so ein paar Konstanten. Und gefühlt spielen die auch dadurch, dass da auf der Trainerposition sich schon so lange einfach nichts getan hat. Habe ich das Gefühl, man weiß immer, was man bekommt. Die sind standardstark, die sind stark im Umschalten. Die pressen auch gerne mal hoch. Und bei Heidenheim ist immer was los. Aber vielleicht ist das jetzt auch alles nur ein Heidenheim-Klischee, was ich gerade bediene. Wenn ich ehrlich bin, so ganz genau weiß ich es gar nicht, wie es in der Saison ist. Kannst du mir da helfen?
Ja, es ist schon irgendwie immer wieder überraschend. Also sie spielen ja glaube ich jetzt das dritte oder vierte Jahr doch irgendwie da oben mit. Mit ihren relativ, ja, also jetzt nicht die größten Namen in dieser Mannschaft. Wer vielleicht noch in der Liga bekannt ist, das ist jemand natürlich wie Marc Schnatterer, obwohl nach meinem Empfinden, der diese Saison nicht die übergeordnete Rolle spielt, die er die letzten Jahre gespielt hat. Also Heidenheim wird unabhängiger von Schnatterer. Man hat aber jemand Spielstarkes wie beispielsweise Konstantin Kerschbaumer geholt, der zwar in seinem Jahr in Ingolstadt nicht sonderlich viel auf die Reihe bekommen hat. Aber wenn man dem mal beim Spielen zuschaut, das ist schon schöner Fußball. Also der ist antrittstark, der ist echt schnell, aber der kann eben auch Tore schießen. Also sowohl als Assistgeber als auch selber als Ballverwerter ist der echt gut. Und das Heidenheim ist schon spielstark. Also das ist immer so eine Mannschaft, die man auch weniger auf dem Zettel hat erst mal. Aber immer wenn es heißt, ja es geht am Wochenende nach Heidenheim, gerade in Heidenheim, das ist immer ein ziemlich garstiges Spiel. Weil die halt wirklich auch gerade in der letzten Saison erinnere ich mich an viele Situationen, die glaube ich drei Chancen hatten. Der Gegner 20 und sie haben trotzdem irgendwie 3-1 gewonnen. Also die nutzen ihre Chancen auch ziemlich gut. Und sie spielen halt also was da seit Jahren läuft unter Frank Schmidt ist natürlich echt solide. Und die haben halt das Glück im Gegensatz zu anderen Mannschaften, die den letzten Jahr noch mal oben mitgespielt haben, dass sie irgendwie nicht jedes Jahr ihren Trainer verlieren.
Ja und dann kommen eben die von dir angesprochenen guten Platzierungen raus. In den letzten drei Saisons ist man einmal fünfte geworden, einmal dreizehnther, einmal sechster. Ach komm, wir nehmen noch den nächsten zwei Saisons mit dazu. Da ist man nämlich einmal elfter geworden und einmal achter. Also wir sehen jedes zweite Jahr wird es zweistellig. Gut, da laufen sie jetzt gerade außerhalb der Serie. Aber ansonsten eben immer im absolut gesicherten Mittelfeld. Und wir dürfen ja nicht vergessen, das ist ja jetzt auch erst die sechste Zweitligasaison von Heidenheim. Also kann man natürlich aus beiden Richtungen sehen, aber wenn wir wissen, vorher haben die keine Rolle gespielt, im Profifußball, in der zweiten Liga zumindest, dann ist das halt einfach schon eine bemerkenswerte Konstanz. Und dann haben wir Aue auf 6. Da hattest du jetzt einen genaueren Blick drauf, was auch dem Spieltag geschuldet war. Die sind sehr, sehr heimstark. Sie haben ein sehr ausgeglichenes Torverhältnis mit 29 erzielten Toren, 27 kassierten Toren und auch bei den Siegen unentschieden Niederlagen ist das mit 8-6-6 sehr gleich verteilt. Ist es jetzt dann so eine Momentaufnahme, dass die so weit oben stehen? Wie würdest du das einschätzen?
Ich tue mich ja auch immer ein bisschen schwer, am 20. Spieltag dann noch von Momentaufnahme zu sprechen. Die sind schon –also wenn man das mal vergleicht zu letzter Saison, und solche Vergleiche werden ja immer ganz gerne gezogen, da haben sie ja irgendwie vorletzter Spieltag oder auf jeden Fall Richtung Ende April ja noch so mit Achung krach den Klassenerhalt geholt. Und wenn man das dieses Jahr vergleicht, also irgendwie, wie du schon sagst, sehr starke Heimannschaft, also punktetechnisch sind sie in der Tabelle, in der Heimtabelle gleich mit Stuttgart. Es geht nur um die Tor-Differenz. Für mich ist es wirklich die größte Überraschung der Saison bisher, weil vor der Saison hatte ich die als klaren Abstiegskandidaten drin. Ja, es ist schon ein bisschen überraschend, würde ich sagen, gerade auch unter Dirk Schuster, der jetzt ja auch nicht der erfolgreichste Trainer der 2. Liga ist, außer irgendwie mal mit Darmstadt. Wer da zu erforben ist, ist ja jemand wie Jan Hochschalt, der ja irgendwie Gefühl trifft und trifft und trifft und man immer denkt, wie sieht der Körper jetzt nicht so aus, als könnte der das? Und jemand im Tor wie Martin Mennel, der ein super Rückhalt ist, der seit Jahren bei Aue spielt, der der 2. Liga-Spieler ist mit den meisten Einsätzen auch. Ich glaube, der ist auch fast seit zehn Jahren jetzt im Club. Das ist schon ziemlich stark, was die da diese Saison abspulen und die sind halt wirklich giftig zu spielen. Also auswärts sind sie eine Katastrophe tatsächlich. Also da stehen sie glaube ich sehr, sehr weit unten auch in der Tabelle.
Nur sechs Punkte geholt aus zehn Spielen.
Genau, aber heim sind sie halt wirklich stark. Da hat Stuttgart zum Beispiel auch nur unentschieden gespielt, Bielefeld jetzt auch, weil die haben auch, findest du jetzt auch nicht so dramatisch, sich dann eben ab der 45. Minute nur noch hinten reinzustellen und die halt jedes mögliche Spielaufbauspiel, also irgendwas, was irgendwie mal durch die Reihen geht, das blocken die die komplett ab, die bleibt endlich nur noch übrig, über hinten zu spielen oder versuchen, dich irgendwie in der Mitte durchzutanken. Und da haben sie natürlich auch relativ viele Ballgewinne, machen da relativ wenig draus, habe ich so das Gefühl. Dafür jemanden wie Nazarauf oder so oder eben auch Hochschalt, die kann man auch zum Teil einfach mal außer Gefecht setzen. Aber es kommen jetzt halt eben noch etwas heftigere Auswärtsspieler auf die zu, zum Beispiel in Stuttgart. Ich glaube, da werden sie sich ganz schön schwer tun. Oder zum Beispiel auch Auswärtsspieler in Kiel und Osnabrück. Auch Osnabrück ist kein leichter Auswärtsgegner, die sind auch relativ heimstark. Ich glaube, da wird es noch mal eine kleine Krise für die geben. Aber ich würde trotzdem sagen, dass sie nicht weit unter Platz 10 landen diese Saison, weil da wirklich gute Arbeit gemacht wird.
Und Aue gehört zumindest mein Herz ein bisschen. Denn gemeinsam mit Dynamo Dresden schlagen sie die wenigsten Flanken der zweiten Liga. Ist doch schön, wenn so etwas belohnt wird. Bei Dresden nicht, aber bei Aue.
Ich würde gerade sagen, so bei ein paar anderen Vereinen nicht so richtig.
Ja, ist mir dann auch aufgefallen, während ich es zitiert habe. Lass uns schnell weitermachen. Wir können logischerweise leider nicht auf alle Vereine blicken. Wir wollen jetzt aber noch kurz ein paar herausnehmen, die so ein bisschen unter dem Stichwort enttäuschend abzulegen sind. Oder zumindest stellen sich da gewisse Fragen. Wir springen mal runter auf Tabellenplatz Nummer 12. Da liegt der FC St. Pauli punktgleich mit Nürnberg und Hannover, über die wir auch gleich nochmal kurz sprechen wollen. Wie läuft denn die Saison für St. Pauli unter Jost Luhokaj?
Ich würde sagen, dass sie sehr unter ihren Möglichkeiten spielen. Die haben generell keinen schlechten Kader. Die haben Leute wie Marvin Knoll, der super war bei Regensburg, der unter Luhokaj kaum eine Rolle spielt. Die sind auswärts katastrophal. Da sind die noch schlechter als Aue. Die haben nämlich nur vier Punkte geholt. Dafür hat man zu Hause unter anderem gegen den HSV gewonnen und gegen Bielefeld. Aber acht Niederlagen sind schon eine Hausnummer. Es war letztes Jahr schon so, dass man die letzten drei Jahre kriselt. Das ist unfassbar in diesem Verein. Gerade zur Winterpause hat mich das schon sehr überrascht. Ich glaube, das hat mehrere Leute überrascht, dass man keinen Ersatz für Möller-Deli geholt hat. Das war jetzt auch kein Last-Minute-Abgang. Das war relativ schnell noch im Dezember klar. Und ich denke mal, St. Pauli ist jetzt auch kein so unaktivierter Verein, dass man da keinen Ersatz hätte bekommen können. Und dann hat man ja auch 3-0 gegen Fürth verloren. Jetzt das 1-1 gegen Stuttgart war schon wieder besser. Aber ja, St. Pauli ist so ein bisschen auch die negative Wundertüte in dieser Saison. Also die spielen nach meinem Empfinden wirklich stark unter ihren Möglichkeiten und müssen wirklich aufpassen, dass sie mal noch ein paar Spiele gewinnen. Weil sonst wird das nämlich zum Ende der Saison noch mal richtig eng.
Aktuell zwei Punkte Vorsprung auf Tabellen. Platz 16 und 17 mit diesen 22 Punkten. Also über alle Vereine, über die wir jetzt sprechen, die stecken da schon tief unten drin. Es gibt in der zweiten Liga einen kleinen Punkte-Cut zwischen Platz 11 und 10, zumindest aktuell. Da ist so ein bisschen die Wasserscheide zwischen, steckt man noch im gesichert Mittelfeld, oder muss man nach unten gucken, das ist zwischen 27 und 23 Punkten. Und Darmstadt hat die 23, ab da geht's spätestens los, dass man sagen muss, okay, da sind halt nur drei Punkte auf den direkten Abstiegsplatz. Wie sieht es denn beim ersten FC Nürnberg aus? Mit Jens Keller haben wir da ja einen neuen Trainer. Ich habe auch das Gefühl gehabt, dass der Club eine der Mannschaften war, für die die Winterpause einfach sehr wichtig war, um sich auf den Trainer ein bisschen einzustellen, ein bisschen zu sich zu finden. Jetzt wird es fast ein bisschen esoterisch, aber das war nur so mein Eindruck von außen. Und zumindest die kurzfristigen Ergebnisse bestätigen mich, ja, eins so überhaupt nicht und das andere dann irgendwie wieder doch. Also das Spiel beim HSV 1 zu 4 verloren, da war sehr wenig zu sehen von Nürnberg gegen Sandhausen, die nicht zu unterschätzen sind in der Saison. Jetzt aber dann in Unterzahl 2 zu 0 gewonnen. Die haben allerdings auch einen Elfmeter verschossen, Sandhausen. Wo liegt jetzt dann die Wahrheit? Ich bin jetzt der, der hier mit ganz wenig Wissen gerade viel zu viel über Nürnberg sagt. Was sagt denn die mit etwas mehr Wissen bis viel Wissen? Ich weiß nicht, wie genau du dich mit dem Club beschäftigst.
Also ich glaube, Nürnbergs größte Achilles-Verse in dieser Saison sind die Torhüter. Also man musste ja zwischenzeitlich den fünften Torhüter gegen Bochum einsetzen. Das ist schon was, ich glaube, unser Verein hat noch nicht mal fünf Torhüter, die man irgendwie einsetzen könnte. Das ist schon, wenn da irgendwie jede Woche ein neuer Torhüter zwischen den Pfosten steht, ist natürlich für das Selbstbewusstsein und für den Rückhalt nicht wirklich förderlich, vor allem, wenn man spielt wie Nürnberg spielt. Man hat ja generell keine schlechten Leute in der Mannschaft, also jemanden wie Dove Dahn, der aus Heidenheim kam, der eine super Saison letzte Saison gespielt hat, und jemanden wie Robin Hack, der jetzt, glaube ich, auch U21-Nationalspieler ist, wenn ich jetzt keinen Schwachsinn erzähle, der auch wirklich ein super Fußballer ist. Aber irgendwie macht Nürnberg da weiter, wo sie mit ihrem Abstieg aus der ersten Liga aufgehört haben. Also da geht irgendwie überhaupt nichts. Sie haben ja genauso, also alle drei Mannschaften, über die wir gerade jetzt reden, haben alle 22 Punkte, alle fünf Siege, alle sieben Unentschieden und alle acht Niederlagen. Auch sehr interessant, sich das mal anzugucken. Aber irgendwie ist Nürnberg wirklich, also da haben Bielefeld jetzt beispielsweise auch 5-1 gewonnen. Das war das erste Spiel unter Jens Keller. Da waren die ersten 15 Minuten so abgetastet und dachte so, das könnte noch mal eng werden für Bielefeld. Aber sobald die ja ein Gegentor kassieren, sind da ja alle scheuen offen. Also war das Spiel gegen den HSV, natürlich hat der HSV auch gewonnen durch zwei Elfmeter. Aber ich meine, so dumm muss man auch erstmal sein, die beiden zu verursachen. Und ich glaube, gerade offensiv geht da erstaunlich wenig. Klar, gegen Sandhausen hat man gewonnen, was eben auch nicht einfach ist. Wie bereits gesagt, weil Sandhausen unterschätzt man auch immer ganz gerne. Aber trotzdem ist es wirklich zu wenig, was momentan da läuft. Und wenn man guckt, dass man gerade so über Wiesbaden steht und über Karlsruhe, also zwei Aufsteiger, aber unter Osnabrück beispielsweise, unter Darmstadt, das ist schon nicht gut. Und da ist, glaube ich, im kompletten Umfeld gerade nach der 4-1-Niederlage war da auch sehr viel Unmut zu hören.
Zweit schlechteste Abwehr mit 38 Gegentreffern. 25 dieser 38 Tore hat man aus dem laufenden Spiel heraus kassiert. Das heißt, der FC Klub steht einfach nicht gut. Und dann kommen noch so Torhütte-Geschichten mit dazu. Da ist natürlich völlig recht, das anzusprechen. Das sieht alles nicht so gut aus. Da muss sich noch ein bisschen was tun, aber man hat ja auf der Trainerposition gewechselt. Damir Kanadi, mit dem ging es in die Saison hinein. Inzwischen ist Jens Keller auf der Bank des R-Club zu finden. Und wir gucken uns an, wie es da weitergeht. Vielleicht auch so ein bisschen in Abgrenzung zu dem Verein, der eben mit der identischen Bilanz, du hast es ja schon angesprochen, hinter dem Klub noch liegt aktuell, nämlich Hannover 96. Ich habe so das Gefühl, die haben bei beiden ist die Stimmung schlecht. Nur habe ich das Gefühl, dass das Hannover-Fans, vielleicht sind die auch einfach noch pessimistischer, aber da lese ich noch weniger Hoffnung heraus aus allem, was ich so mitbekomme aus dem Fanumfeld, jetzt über soziale Netzwerke und durch persönliche Kontakte.
Ja, da muss man sich glaube ich auch einfach nur mal die Stadion-Auslastung angucken. Also wo bei Nürnberg immer noch irgendwie gefühlt volle Hütte ist, guckt man bei Hannover immer auf leere Ränge. Sie spielen halt auch wirklich keinen attraktiven Fußball. Solche Neuzugänge wie Dennis Aogo, die nach drei Monaten wieder aus dem Vertrag gelassen werden und als großer Hoffnungsträger angekündigt wurden, das macht natürlich auch nicht wirklich Hoffnung. Jetzt hat man auch jemanden aus Schweden geholt, glaube ich, der als großer Hoffnungsträger kam, der auch irgendwie, wenn man sich da mal die Statistiken anguckt, jetzt nicht unbedingt der beste Spieler auf dem Markt war. Ja, und dann ist ja generell das Thema Martin Kind in diesem Verein auch nicht mehr so ganz einfach. Also wenn man jetzt irgendwie hört, dass man den Vorstand da rausschmeißt und dann irgendjemand wieder reinholt, mit dem der Verein gerade in Rechtsstreit steht, denkt man sich natürlich auch, wie viel läuft da eigentlich momentan falsch. Und das trägt natürlich auch nicht dazu bei, dass so eine Mannschaft gesichert dasteht. Also man hat ja eigentlich einen Top-Torhüter mit Ron Rovers Zieler. Trotzdem läuft die Saison natürlich komplett unter den Vorstellungen. Also ich glaube, man hat sich das schon etwas leichter vorgestellt. Persönlich dachte ich auch, die gehören eher als Nürnberg wieder zu den Aufstiegsrängen dazu. Aber da läuft natürlich irgendwie gar nichts zusammen. Also die ganzen Hoffnungsträger schlagen auch überhaupt nicht ein. Der Fußball ist unfassbar unattraktiv. Und naja, es ist wirklich nicht gut, was da momentan läuft. Auch dieses Spiel gegen Wien, Wiesbaden beispielsweise, wo man es irgendwie nicht schafft, eine 2-1-Führung mal gerade noch über die letzten fünf Minuten zu bringen. Und das Spiel Absteiger gegen Aussteiger gegeneinander. Und Wiesbaden ist jetzt auch nur ein Punkt unter Hannover. Also jetzt aber auch nicht die Überraschungsmannschaft der Saison. Da erwartet man von jemandem wie Hannover schon eindeutig mehr.
Ich meine, es ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen eine Frage des Maßstabs. Also zum Beispiel bei den Zuschauerzahlen. Ich habe auch die nicht mal zu einem Drittel gefüllte HDI-Arena im Kopf, wenn ich an Hannover 96 denke. Und gerade jetzt beim letzten Spiel war es wirklich traurig. Allerdings ist da halt auch tatsächlich der Referenzrahmen wichtig. Das liegt da dran, weil es halt auch eine 49.000-er-Arena ist. Und nach dem Zuschausschnitt liegt Hannover immer noch auf Platz 5 in der Liga. Und das ist, glaube ich, so ein bisschen sinnbildlich für Hannover 96. Dass halt dadurch, dass man weiß, woher Hannover 96 kommt, welche Mittel man auch dann doch immer noch hat, allen sonstigen Problemen zutrotz, dass es dafür halt einfach so wenig ist. Und der Schwede, der gekommen ist, ist Dominik Kaiser. Der war früher mal bei Rasenballspot Leipzig. Also der kam von Brönnby. Ich wollte jetzt nicht sagen, dass er Schwede ist.
Ich meine, sie hätten auch noch einen Schweden verpflichtet, der aber einen leicht italienisch angehauchten Namen hat.
Ja, natürlich.
Du hast recht. Und ich meine, der hat sich aber auch schon wieder verletzt. Wenn ich richtig liege. Also auf jeden Fall ist er für das Wien-Spiel, glaube ich, ausgefallen oder so ähnlich. Also alles keine Idealmischungen tatsächlich.
Nee, nee, das kann man, glaube ich, so festhalten bei Hannover 96. Gut, irgendwie ziehen sich da auch rote, rote Felden durch. Sonn Gedeiti ist ausgefallen gegen Wiesbaden. Da hast du natürlich völlig recht. Dann haben wir mit Wien, Wiesbaden, Bochum, dem KSC und Dynamo Dresden noch vier Mannschaften, die dahinter liegen. Müssen wir jetzt nicht auf alle im Detail eingehen bzw. können sie jetzt auch nicht aus zeitlichen Gründen. Wen findest du denn da jetzt noch besonders bemerkenswert bzw. bei wem hast du vielleicht auch das Gefühl, da könnte sich noch was verändern? Die haben ja alle Punkte technisch, vor allem natürlich Wien, Wiesbaden, Bochum und der KSC. Da ist ja noch alles drin Richtung Nichtabstieg.
Ja, wenn beispielsweise Bochum heute Abend gegen den HSV gewinnen würde, würde man glaube ich aufgrund des besseren Torverhältnisses als Darmstadt auf Platz 11 springen. Also das wäre schon ein gewaltiger Sprung. Und bei Bochum ist es so ein bisschen überraschend, die haben eine echt gute Offensive tatsächlich. Also unter den ganzen Mannschaften, die da unten rumgucken, haben die die beste. Aber man hat halt irgendwie nur vier Siege in dieser Saison zu verbuchen. Sieben Niederlagen, acht Unentschieden. Viele dieser Unentschieden, zum Beispiel das Spiel gegen Wien-Wiesbaden, wo man zur Halbzeit 3-0 zurückgelegen hat, dann irgendwie noch das 3-3 rausgeholt hat. Auch das Spiel gegen Bielefeld, das Sinsspiel. Bielefeld hat 2-0 geführt, dann hat Bochum 3-2 geführt und dann kriegt man in der Nachspielzeit oder auf jeden Fall in der 90. Saison irgendwie noch so ein Eigentor da rein. Die Defensive steht wirklich unfassbar schlecht, also das ist auch durch im Bochumer Umfeld so zu hören. Man hatte so das Gefühl, dass in der Winterpause echt viel gut gelaufen ist. Man hat ein paar Spiele einfach mal zu Null gewonnen, also auch unter anderem gegen Uerdingen beispielsweise. Nur hat man irgendwann beispielsweise gegen Bielefeld, das jüngste Spiel, was man hier tatsächlich auch analysieren kann, weil das HSV-Spiel jetzt ja erst noch folgt, startet man mit sieben defensiven Spielern auf dem Platz. Und dann ist natürlich klar, dass der Zug zum Tor komplett fehlt und dann kann ich auch kein Tor schießen. Also selbst wenn man nur 1-0 hinten liegt, brauche ich trotzdem jemanden, der vorne schießt. Man hat da Leute, die es können, mit Simon Zoller, Zivert Ganvula, Tom Weiland, das sind alles keine schlechten Spieler, die auch schon in der 2.Liga alle getroffen haben, aber es läuft halt unfassbar viel falsch. Sebastian Schinzi-Lord steht auch harsh in der Kritik, also man hat, glaube ich, versucht, drei Spieler zu verpflichten, war sich auch immer schon mit den Spielern einig, nur leider hat der Verein auf der anderen Seite immer gesagt, ne, ne, wollen wir nicht. Also unter anderem Lasse Zubich, der mit St. Pauli unfassbar viel 2.Liga-Erfahrung hat, aber auch Jung von Brönnby oder zuletzt, glaube ich, stand auch Zier-Eis von St. Pauli auf der Wunschliste, das hat nur leider alles nicht geklappt. Dazu kommt, dass man jemanden mit Manuel Riemann im Tor hat, der sehr emotional werden kann, weshalb er auch mit Gelb rot vom Platz geflogen ist innerhalb von zwei Minuten. Also im Prinzip das erste Opfer dieser etwas herrscheren Schiedsrichter-Reihe jetzt war. Übrigens auch der erste Spieltag seit Januar 2017, wo zwei Torhüter vom Platz geflogen sind an einem Spieltag.
Na guck mal, das ist doch hier das Trivia-Wissen, das man haben möchte.
Ja, der andere war Julius Kühn. Nee, war der Julius Kühn, ist der Handballspieler. Auf jeden Fall von Osnabrück der Torwart, der gegen Sandhausen vom Platz geflogen ist. Ich glaube, er ist auch irgendwas mit J. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Auf jeden Fall spielen sie heute auch mit ihrem Ersatztorwart. Also da läuft sehr, sehr viel falsch bei Bochum. Und eigentlich wäre es schade, weil man halt mit Bielefeld und Bochum die letzten beiden Vereine aus Nordrhein-Westfalen in der 2. Liga und Bochum ist eigentlich auch immer so Currywurst, Ruhestadion, gehört irgendwie zur 2. Liga dazu. Die sind ja auch quasi der zweite Liga-Dino, der Verein, der am längsten in der 2. Liga spielt hintereinander. Aber es wird eben auch nicht einfacher. Also es kommen noch direkte Duellen gegen Dresden unter anderem dazu, aber eben davor das Spiel gegen Stuttgart zu Hause, auch an einem Montagabend, also man hat jetzt diese Woche eben das HSV-Spiel, dann hat man in zwei Wochen das Stuttgart-Spiel, dann geht's auswärts nach Dresden. Wird natürlich alles nicht einfacher für die, aber umso wichtiger ist es, dass man vielleicht irgendwie heute Abend mal einen Punkt mitnimmt, weil das wäre natürlich schon ein Gewinn, und dass man halt wirklich diese Defensive auf die Reihe bekommt. Also das ist schon jemand wie Patrick Fabian, der natürlich unfassbar viel Erfahrung hat, aber irgendwie jeden zweiten Ball weggrätschen muss, weil er vom Tempo nicht hinterherkommt. Das ist natürlich was, was man in der aktuellen Situation auf dem 16. Platz wirklich so als Letztes gebrauchen kann.
Philipp Kühn ist es natürlich, der Torhüter. Aber ich hatte es auch nicht mehr auf dem Zettel. Dann haben wir noch einen Trainerwechsel. Adol Schwarz wurde beim KSC entlassen, eben auch mit 20 Punkten auf Tabellenplatz 17. Aktuell der KSC hat auch so ein ganz interessanter Saisonverlauf. Ich glaube, da wird man im letzten Zweitliga-Kurzpass dann mal genauer draufgucken müssen. Die sind eigentlich ganz gut gestartet. Dann gab es eine unglaubliche Serie von sieben Unentschieden in Folge. Und zwar von eins zu eins bis drei zu drei war da alles mal mit dabei. Und auch alles mehrfach, bis auf zwei zu zwei. Das haben sie nur einmal gespielt. Und dann ging es so ein bisschen dahin gegen Stuttgart verloren, noch einmal gewonnen, noch einmal Unentschieden gegen Bielefeld. Da kannst du dich gut dran erinnern. Und jetzt die letzten vier Partien waren allesamt sehr schmerzhaft für den KSC. Eins zu fünf gegen Kräuter-Voort zu Hause, null zu eins gegen Wien-Wiesbaden. Und jetzt dann im Januar und Februar null zu eins bei Dynamo Dresden verloren. Die sind dadurch wieder in der Verlosung für den Nichtabstieg. Und jetzt zu Hause null zu zwei gegen Heustern-Kiel. Das war dann zu viel. Und Adolf Schwarz wurde entlassen. Ja, ich könnte noch lange mit dir über die zweite Liga sprechen. Könnte ich wirklich. Es ist keine Floske. Wir haben ja auch nicht mal alle Vereine durchgesprochen. Aber das ist halt leider auch nicht möglich. Eva, ich danke dir sehr herzlich, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast für den Rasenfunk.
Ich danke herzlich für die Einladung. Es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich. Und es ist ja vielleicht auch gar nicht so wild, dass wir noch ein paar Lücken gelassen haben. Weil dann sollen die Leute halt einfach den zweiten Bundesliga-Podcast hören und abonnieren. Das kriegen wir doch alle hin. Und vor allem, also wer sich für die zweite Bundesliga interessiert, der ist ja quasi schon direkt am internationalen Fußball dran.
Ja, und wer möchte, kann auch gerne Matthew Karacic folgen. Der macht auch sehr viele Spieltagsanalysen, immer zu spielen in der zweiten Liga. Also wer da noch ein bisschen mehr auf die Taktikschiene geht, macht viel für Football Bloody Hell. Auch sehr veranschaulicht, dem sei das auch sehr ans Herz gelegt.
Absolut, Matthew Karacic mit G-I-C-H hinten dran. Aber wenn man dem 2. Bundesliga-Pod auf Twitter folgt, dann findet man ihn sehr schnell. Eva, ich danke dir sehr herzlich und bin sehr gespannt, wo die Arminia landen wird in dieser Saison.
Ich auch.
Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr könnt den Rasenfunk gerne unterstützen, wenn ihr wollt. Unter rasenfunk.de/unterstützenerfahrtihr, wie das geht. Auf kiosk.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr schicken, Merch kaufen und auch in der 2. Bundesliga den Rasenfunk repräsentieren. In diesem Sinne hören wir uns hoffentlich bald wieder an diesem Ort und dieser Stelle. Bis dahin, macht's gut.